it's the end of months of speculation
and tension Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo has officially signaled that the
arms control treaty which has helped
keep Europeans safe could soon end if
Russia does not return to full and
verifiable compliance with the treaty
within this six-month period by
verifiably destroying its INF violating
missiles their launchers and associated
equipment the treaty will terminate this
is the weapon that the u.s. is talking
about the Russian built SS c8 a missile
system Washington and many experts
believe has a range of more than 500
kilometers which would mean it's a
violation of the INF treaty but the
Kremlin says it never intended to
violate the agreement a Russian Foreign
Ministry spokesperson says the u.s.
ultimatum is part of a strategy to dodge
its international legal obligations for
many European countries the end of the
INF treaty brings back memories of the
Cold War and it Stokes fears of a new
arms race the German Chancellor Angela
Merkel called on both sides to continue
talks first it's clear that Russia has
violated the treaty and that's why we
must talk to Russia on behalf of Germany
foreign minister high commerce and
myself we'll do everything to make talks
possible again in the next six months
the agreements between the US and the
former Soviet Union banned all
land-based nuclear missiles with a range
between 500 and five-and-a-half thousand
kilometers it marked an end to decades
of nuclear instability during the Cold
War experts now fear the end of the INF
treaty could not only further damage the
transatlantic relationship but also
threaten the future of other arms
control agreements CW's Washington
bureau chief alexander phenomen told us
what is likely to happen next with the
INF treaty between the u.s. and russia
secretary pompeius announcement starts a
six-month clock that trump
administration officials believe will
end with a full American withdrawal from
the treaty
beginning on Saturday the US would be
free to start testing and deploying its
own weapons it's not clear this will
happen but experts here fear this is
just an opening shot in a new global
arms race well from war in the story
we're joined now by Michael Baranov ski
he's the director of the German Marshall
Fund office in Warsaw Michael thanks so
much for being with us so what do you
believe is likely to happen if the
United States does indeed exit the
nuclear treaty for good so it's true
that United States started the clock on
withdrawing from the INF treaty but we
all have to remember that there is a
full agreement in NATO then it was
Russia who first violated and in fact
broke the INF treaty by testing and
fielding the intermediate nuclear
weapons that they are already have in
stock so we are talking about three to
four battalions of the forbidden
missiles that Russia has already fielded
and as you're as we could hear
Chancellor Merkel is in full agreement
with this so us is withdrawing now but
it's Russia that that drove their
treatment I don't expect anything
immediate to change right now because
the u.s. does not have capabilities to
put in the field that you need it will
take years for us to develop such
weapons all right so you say that NATO
has pointed the finger at Russia blaming
it for violating the treaty you say it's
gonna take a while for the u.s. to
develop anything but do we expect to be
entering a new arms race not on the
western side it would be we will kill
ourselves we will be will be lying to
ourselves if we thought that you are not
in an arms race right now it's Russia
who is developing those weapons both on
the nuclear front they have
the long range now intermediate range
but also practical smaller nuclear
weapons it's it will take a while or for
NATO and us respond in kind again there
is no disagreement among them to say
NATO countries who is who broke that
that the treatment now it would what we
could see in the short term is that US
or other European powers decides to
field starter medium-range nuclear
weapons that are not land-based there
for example sea bass again it will take
long long time to develop an event-based
missiles they are not ready yet all
right Michael buranovskiye from the
German Marshall Fund Office and Warsaw
many things indeed for your insights
you